Ostentatious, exaggerated, colossal.
It seems that Dubai always aspires to carry
out the largest, most luxurious and most eccentric
projects in the world.
In this small territory we can find the tallest
building, the most luxurious hotel, and even
the largest international airport on the planet.
Located in a strategic enclave at the mouth
of the Persian Gulf, the growth process of
Dubai is one of the fastest in human history.
In just over 20 years it has gone from being
a remote and lost enclave in the desert to
becoming one of the world's great capitals.
In this period of time the emirate of Dubai
has multiplied by four its population, by
nine the number of visitors, and by eight
the size of its economy,
But ... Having said that, the question is:
how has all this development been achieved?
Has it all been just a matter of oil?
Well in this VisualPolitk video we’re going
to talking all about Dubai.
Dubai is one of the seven emirates that make
up the United Arab Emirates.
We could describe its government as an Islamic
autocracy that restricts a large part of its
peoples civil liberties.
However, if we compare it with its neighboring
countries, Dubai is by far the most open place
in the Middle East.
Want some examples?
Well, here women can drive, the veil is not
mandatory, you can buy pork at the supermarket,
and even alcohol is not hard to come by.
Yes... things are starting to change, and
in a way I think we could refer to this city
as a kind of oasis in the middle of the desert.
And, as you can imagine, all of this change
has had its reward.
And, well, it might just suprise you…
Did you know that Dubai is already the fourth
most visited city in the world (when it comes
to international visitors) and that it surpasses
epicenters of tourism and global trade such
as New York, Hong Kong or Singapore?!
Well it totally is, and this is something
that surprises a lot of people!
Of course, there’s one thing we have to
be clear on here, Dubai does not aspire to
be the freest place on earth, but they do
want to become the richest.
Examples of opulence in this place are so
evident that it is not strange to see the
Dubais police patrol the streets in Ferraris
or Lamborghinis...
Where else in the world could you possibly
see something like this?!
Maybe at this moment some of you are thinking
that all this exuberance has a very easy explanation:
oil.
Could it be that Dubai is nothing more than
a dream of sheikhs that’s financed with
petrodollars?
Well, although we can not deny the influence
of black gold, the truth is that the real
key is very different.
The great secret of Dubai is not oil, but
its commitment to trade.
Don't believe me?
Well, let’s dive a little deeper…
NOT ENOUGH OIL
At the end of the 1950s, important oil deposits
were discovered in the vicinity of Abu Dhabi,
the capital of the Emirates.
Be careful here, because we are not talking
about a small discovery, but an a about a
huge amount of oil.
To give you an idea, it is estimated that
the oil wealth of the Emirates - their proven
reserves - is even greater than those of all
Russia.
However, in the case of Dubai it was a bit
different...
It is true that this territory was also graced
with the fortune of black gold ... But its
authorities soon realized that their reserves
were much smaller than those of their compatriots
in Abu Dhabi.
In fact, although it may surprise us, oil
today accounts for less than 1 in every 100
dollars produced by Dubai’s economy...
You’ve probably heard about how important
it is to diversify an economy, right?
Well, that is precisely what Dubai did: overcome
dependence and addiction to oil.
Now this is very easy to say, but ... The
question is:
How did they do it?
What did Dubai do to achieve such development
and achieve a higher standard of living even
compared to its oil-rich neighbors?
Basically, what it did was attract multinationals
and professionals from all around the world.
To achieve this, the first thing they did
was to bet on a low tax policy.
Look, in Dubai they do not have income tax;
the tax on profits is practically non-existent
and currently purchases are not taxed either
- although the latter is about to change.
As a result of a joint agreement of all the
member countries of the Persian Gulf Cooperation
Council, a tax on purchases will soon be launched.
However, the rate will be around 5%, far from
the rates of more than 18% so common in developed
countries.
And, of course, in case you are wondering,
in Dubai there are no taxes on gasoline either.
Yes I know.
It almost seems like we are talking about
another planet…
But do not think that low taxes are the only
strategy Dubai has followed, not at all…
Second, and perhaps even more important than
taxes, Dubai has resorted to an instrument
known as "Special Economic Zones," although
here they are somewhat different from what
we can find elsewhere.
In Dubai, these special areas, in addition
to having tax benefits, even have their own
regulations - almost laws - which, as you
can imagine, are always focused on promoting
business activity.
Precisely, thanks to having specific rules,
companies can escape the rigidity of legal
systems that are inspired by sharia law; something
that applies, of course in the rest of the
emirates…
We can find a good example of this model in
the so-called "Dubai International Financial
Center", which is almost a state within another
state.
Look, this Financial Center has its own judicial
system - chaired by the way, by a British
judge; with its own official language, which
is not Arabic but English; and has even replaced
the local currency with the US dollar…
In this way a financial institution, a bank
for example, can do business as if it were
in Manhattan but benefiting from the tax advantages
of Dubai.
Not a bad deal, right?
So, now we can understand how Dubai has managed
to attract the most of the 25 largest banks
in the world.
But ... This is not all.
Along with low taxes and Special Economic
Zones, Dubai also opted for a very high degree
of immigration freedom.
The result?
96% of its inhabitants have been born abroad.
But wait, because there's more...
To further boost foreign investment, at the
beginning of this century the Dubai authorities
made an unprecedented decision for this corner
of the world.
BREAKING MOLDS
In 2002 the government of Dubai approved a
risky decree that allowed any foreigner, regardless
of their religion, to make real estate investments.
At that moment the authentic boom began.
Dubai was full of buildings and large projects:
hundreds of skyscrapers, gigantic shopping
centers and even the famous artificial islands.
Now the demand for Dubai become global.
It’s a fact that since 2002, Dubai has experienced
real estate development comparable only to
that of Shanghai, a city with 13 times more
inhabitants.
Because another one of the most surprising
things about Dubai is that it has less than
3 million inhabitants…
Despite this, where before there were only
a handful of skyscrapers, thanks to this decree
there are now hundreds and huge projects are
announced one after the other... be it new
skyscrapers, ferris wheels or theme parks.
One of these latest projects, by the way,
is known as "The Mall of the World", a gigantic
space destined to become the largest shopping
center in the world, and which will even house
its own cultural district with dozens of theaters
and cinemas, one hundred hotels, and the largest
indoor theme park in the world.
The project has been presented as the world’s
first city with a temperature controlled environment!
Well, all these measures have made Dubai a
place where it is easy to do business and
have turned this emirate into a commercial,
touristic, financial, logistical, and even
industrial power.
Yes, anyone who thinks that all this Dubai
thing is only about banks and hotels is very
wrong…
Nowadays, Dubai, thanks largely to its modern
ports and special zones, is the third largest
re-exporting power in the world and its industrial
production exceeds 50 billion dollars each
year..
This is what explains why its neighbors are
uneasily watching any fall in the price of
oil, while the government of Dubai continues
to carry out large projects.
It is true, from a strictly political point
of view there are still many reprehensible
elements when it comes to its religious, social
or human rights issues.
There are, for example, the painful conditions
suffered by many construction workers from
countries such as India, Bangladesh or Pakistan.
Of course we can not ignore this reality,
but we can not not paying attention to the
achievements of this emirate.
Among other things because thanks to this,
Dubai has managed to influence the policies
its neighbors are implementing and encouraging
them to reduce their dependence on oil.
Dubai is, quite simply, a great model.
There is, for example, the new Saudi Arabia
of Mohammed Bin Salman, of which we have already
spoken about in a previous video.
Anyway, I think this case puts a very important
question on the table: Is it possible to reconcile
the absence of civil rights with sustainable
economic growth over time?
History and empirical evidence seem to show
that it is not the situation, but in a world
increasingly pressured by very high taxes
and regulations of all kinds, Dubai’s authorities
seem intent on demonstrating that this time
it will be possible.
At the moment, its commitment to free trade
and investment, and its policies aimed at
strengthening legal security, ease of doing
business and keeping taxes low, have been
superlative.
If anything, Dubai shows us that competitiveness
and trade tend to have better results in terms
of development than protectionism or subsidies.
Many rulers should pay attention to the successes
of this oasis in the desert.
But having said that, now its your turn.
Do you think the Dubai model will make the
Middle East a freer place?
Leave your answer in the comments below as
well as in the survey.
I really hope you enjoyed this video, please
hit like if you did and don’t forget to
subscribe to our channel for brand new videos
every Monday and Thursday.
Also, don’t forget to check out our friends
at the Reconsider Media Podcast - they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not mine!
And as always, thanks for watching!